have you ever killed someone and how did
that feel
the tough one
[Music]
I joined the army at 16 I joined the
household Cavalry the blues and Ross and
and then my career path went Polar
Opposites uh became a sniper and uh yeah
they ended up doing 10 tours of
Frontline fighting and then um this is
where I am now
I left school of 14 because of those
days
14 was a good ageless school I suppose
at 17 I was caught up with a regular
army at the outbreak award the beginning
of September but the 9th of September I
think it was
and I was on the ant aircraft events in
London
during the Blitz
and there was a gun layer on the three
inch guns first week of the war door now
flying boat came over on reconnaissance
and uh
came over very close and I aimed a gun
at it through the open sights and
unfortunately instead of knocking the
aircraft out the sky I put this kitchen
chimney down and nobody had any
breakfast that morning I weren't very
happy I can assure you hi so I joined
the RAF on my 19th birthday and after
seeing a magazine in a career's office
back over Northern Ireland actually
because my brother was joining the Army
a year before me and I saw this Magazine
with the person hanging outside of a
helicopter on a rope well I thought it
was a rope and I said to the guy and you
informed what this guy's job it looks
really cool and he said well it's um
helicopter equipment and it's a wire not
a rope that he's hanging out on and I
just went that's the coolest job in the
whole wide world and I wanted it so um
yeah did all the um entrance tests to
get into the RAF I managed to join up on
my 19th birthday and went straight to
Chinook helicopters and spent 17 years
flying on those and a bit like Craig
ended up in a rack twice for two tours
and then did 10 tours in Helmand as part
of Bob parrick a nap in 2019. hi Joe in
the Royal Marine Commandos when I was
18.
um I came over from South Africa had a
bit of a destructive childhood and was
just looking for
I guess of something
of a family and a Brotherhood
unfortunately when
I was 24 I
was on a operation where we were after a
high value Target and I was
unfortunately shot through the neck
which
paralyzing instantly from the neck down
what can you compare being in combat to
how does it feel there's nothing yeah
you can't compare it to anything
the adrenaline
um
the way you feel you you I don't know
you laugh sometimes when you you
enormous laugh because you're really
yeah
over the years
um from when I first got to Afghanistan
you know we'd go into some Landing sites
that have been either mortared or
rocketed the day before or like some of
the fogs that have been in contact that
morning and then we were allowed to go
in
um and then as Herrick got more kinetic
we would then for some of the merch
shots for some of the guys who had who
were T1 so that's the worst kind of
injury we had to get them out because
they had an hour to live we would then
have to go in while the landing site was
still in con under contact but it became
normal your normality bar for fear if
that makes sense kind of started to
climb over the years and certainly for
guys who've done multiple tours by the
time you know you're sat and there's
bullets within past you it kind of feels
normal an albino Yugoslav it's like
these people you know Afghan and Iraq
nine times out of ten we didn't know
where our enemies were because they
weren't in uniform
and you had and the rules engagement
which they told us about to do we had to
wait for them to fire on us before we
fired on them hasn't changed which was
completely ridiculous
because you could have a farmer digging
his trenches and he'd have a machine gun
in his
and he's just opened fire first
so it's a different type of warfare
Behind Enemy Lines especially that
that's really interesting hearing John
say that because I say he creates
nodding until we all get this too the
Taliban switched onto that they were
really clever and we used to land at
some sites and they'd have an RPG and
point at us and as long as if they put
it down and walked away we can jit them
even though we knew they had left on
Town towards us unless they're
physically aimed at the aircraft we
couldn't do anything about it which
meant that they could go and collect it
pick it up again and fire it these guys
but because the rules we get are so
strict and it was self-defense you know
you could only ever pull the trigger if
you had honest belief that you were
going to get shot out and it put you in
a very Catch-22 scenario have you ever
killed someone and how did that feel
it's a tough one yeah
me personally as a sniper yes I have
what did it feel like felt pretty
excited to begin with fault I was in
trouble
um
always
in a situation where I had to because I
was saving other people from this one
person you know and it had to be done
had the permission to do it the green
lights you have to go through all this
stigma of green light so God knows what
and because I've got a precision rifle
with a scope I can PID that Target and I
know what I'm looking at yeah and you
feel like you're in trouble and I felt
for about a week I thought I was going
to get a tap on the shoulder all the
time going can we have a quick word of
you you know why did you kill this guy
you know and then
and then it I didn't look at them as
people after that I just looked at them
as targets because if you start looking
at them as people you start thinking
there are people and you start you know
your mind starts you're overthinking
your what your actions and what you're
doing
I think for me
it was a lot easier
um
and then and this was my experience
being in the Special Forces was that
compared to being on on you know genetic
generic forces on the ground was
we had different rules of engagement and
in some respects it was a lot easier it
was easier being a sniper as well
because we had Ops to go once yeah take
Pacific targets Out and because you've
got that scope on that rifle you can
actually PID that you know exactly yeah
I I didn't make and stuff like that you
can actually be idea and ultimately that
made it
I think it it was easier for your
conscience yeah is there
one kind of memory
which you would say stuck with you
if you can identify one What would
that be do you think
what memory sticks in your mind
what memory sticks in my mind
in what way what the memories yeah yeah
well I think the memory okay which
sticks in my mind is
the comrade ship
which you don't get in civilian life
and we miss it terribly when we come out
of the army
comradeship I think is the most
important memory you can have
you know the comrades you you've missed
out on being killed
they are second yeah banter you can't
beat
especially in Special Forces I think
there's probably more comradeship than
anywhere else yeah
because you work in a club you're there
to help each other
you would never leave a comrade behind
if you could help it one of the saddest
memories that stick with me
um
is their repatriation
where they were their coffin was carried
back on to the back of a Hercules
and we were all standing standing there
um
to attention
without berries on
saluting coffin going you know going
back to the UK on the back of the hook
um
I think that's one of the strongest
memories I have
um only because it just
uh yeah it took my breath away I
couldn't
I can't actually
describe it it was just um
it was just but you talk about a memory
that sticks with you sometimes it's not
always the good memories it's not always
the good memories that stick with you
um and I'm sure these guys will agree
with me there's a lot of good memories
there's also a lot of hard memories
I mean my my memory that I always look
back on Herrick was my we had to go pick
up Five Guys who've been killed at four
Benjamin actually which was up the
valley and five guys have been hitting
one one go
and I remember the the stretchers coming
over the ramp and um
I thought I'm gonna get emotional um
they were all covered in Flags so there
was a rifles flying on one of the bodies
um a Union Jack on one
um a Welsh flag on one of them and each
body had a different flag on it and then
they were the guys set the the stretches
down and and touched the bodies and went
back off into the fight and there's
nothing you can say to those guys that's
gonna make that better
I'm not brothership like that
Brotherhood it was so apparent and there
are faces as they set their mates dying
on the floor and said goodbye for the
last time and you know that's something
that that Brotherhood is just in your
blood forever
sorry
do you think you can form the same bond
in any other way no
civilians do not understand the way
military explanatory work in their
headspace
and I always say PTSD oh yeah we all got
PTSD but it's like a train track
you know they're civilian Peterson
there's military and it's level because
we've got PTSD but it never crossed
because people never understand this and
we will never understand that you know
but it would go parallel with each other
John what about you what about the
people you served with
people
people that you served with memories
well unfortunately uh
my memory General that good I have a
couple of miles just strokes and I lost
a lot of my memory
but uh
people I serve with
I suppose will always be in my memory
because they were very important
they were my comrades is anyone still
around from the people you served with
people around
no I think I'm about one of the two left
I think
there's only two left in my regiment
anyway and why not
do you owe your life to anyone has
anyone saved you yeah I had um
uh early in my early years in
Afghanistan and we were dropping off on
some load up a place called kajaki Dam
which is right at the top of the Hellman
Valley
and um
there's wires like the big sort of high
voltage wires that you get here in the
UK we call those helicopter Killers
because if you fly under set of those
you're more than likely going to pull
the whole aircraft out of the sky so
when we're here in the UK we do lots of
Rockies to make sure that we look for
them and we see them before we'd fly any
navigation routes
um and we kind of do the same in
Afghanistan but they're not marked on
any Maps you just have to keep an eye
out for them and um but this particular
set had been put up and we haven't seen
them so as we dropped an unsung load off
at the drop point
um we've we sort of exited from the drop
point and flew straight into a huge set
of 250 foot high voltage wires
um
and the whole aircraft also there was a
Lloyd Bank
um and
um the first thing I remember was seeing
the the wire spark out in the three
o'clock of the aircraft I was stood at
the front door and the smell of burning
electricity just filled the whole
aircraft really badly
um I looked at my shoulder and the other
crew and had nearly gone through the
center hatch with the jolt of the
airframe had actually been saved by his
harness
um and the whole aircraft was wallowing
towards the ground which was like
engineering sand dunes and the pilot was
just shouting I can't see I can't see so
I thought we were going to crash I held
the front of my harness which is like
two webbing straps it fit into a buckle
and thought that we were absolutely
going to go crash land and I was gonna
have to somehow get out of the aircraft
and about 15 feet off the ground the
co-pilot a guy called Marty and said I
have control I managed to pull in power
and climb this back into the sky and
what had happened the cockpit had caved
in over the handling pilot so he
couldn't say anything but um you know
that champ that day absolutely saved my
life yeah without a doubt for me I
wouldn't be here today if someone didn't
save my life
um
in fact it was probably a few guys who
it was my entire Squadron who saved my
life really
um
we were on a special op
um near the northern border of Afghan
and we were After High Valley targets
once we'd broken through they had all
set up and yeah we just walked into a
wall of bullets
um
there's really nothing we could do about
it I was shot through the neck
second round hit me on the side of the
head but luckily I was you know wearing
my kevlar helmets so I'd Rico Shed off
the guy behind me was shot through the
knee and
um
yeah I was dragged out
uh
as the firefight ensued by the
the team coming in behind me and yeah
they started working on me straight away
in the middle of the night in the pitch
black
um
obviously they didn't know where I'd
been shot so the first thing they were
doing was trying to find the find the
wound fun entry wound
um stop to stem the bleeding uh pack the
wound and
and then keep me breathing so yeah I
really owe my life to about three or
four
guys on the ground my last tour
um
went on an OP I was sniping give an
OverWatch in the green zone
and Yacht went well
civil targets got taken out
you know Happy Days in it you know
as you all know are for
five o'clock in Afghan pitch black you
know
your beautiful ambient light you know
from sorry no ambient light but the
stars are beautiful you know and um
it came to about half four and we had to
finish this up so they went back the
patrol went back and we come off The
High Ground
got my vehicle and three vehicles and my
first core sign stopped
and
as a sergeant you're not meant to lead
you know your Junior course on leads and
the go on someone there and he stopped
and I jumped out my wagon and went round
wearing jackals up on top vehicles
and I said to him you know why aren't we
moving and he said
I've got a bad feeling about this
you know I'm not a religious man I
believe in fate and gut instinct you
know and he said um
I've got wife and kids at home Creek
I went behind me hi
I'll lead
so I've got my vehicle and um
I didn't want to go into the village
because there were too many VPS in the
village
so um vulnerable points so I what I did
I scooted around the village
and I hit a 30 kilo anti-tank mine
I got blown out
um
the other vehicle the left side
my driver hit the steering wheel and
lost his legs
but I couldn't find him and I was trying
to crawl but as I was crawling my arms
were just collapsing on me and I could
hear people and that boo that constant
buzzing sound everything's in slow
motion and I could hear people shouting
behind me stay still stay still stay
still
and I blood picked out my head
everything in the nose ears and I wanted
to find my driver I couldn't see him I
couldn't see him
um
and it turned out that I'd
um armored personnel mines around me
see if I'd have called any further I
would hit an AP mine
um
they found my driver where they've
blasted hit the rights sorry the right
side of the vehicle or the sand went on
him so he was like camouflaged in his
gear plus the sand and the only fan
because of the bloodstock did he survive
yeah he did yeah yeah and um
I remember the lads just wrapping me up
you know their skills and drills took
over you know I wasn't
Craig Harrison then I wasn't Sergeant
Harrison I was a casualty you know and
they had to think as me as a casualty
not you know and they wrapped me up put
me in a
um
stretcher
and took me to the uh
emergency hls and then we got under Fire
and they started engaging us from the
village and from the green zone because
it was quite flat
and the Chinook came down as the Merc
came down it touched and went off again
because it would land because it was
pinging off
the side of the Mur
um
and they were
that we needed it because Cliff was
bleeding out my driver
and it landed again and
I saw I remember I saw I remember and I
remember waking up
um
in hospital
ambastian and I looked over and I saw
blood on this bed there's pure blood on
the bed and it was where my driver was
and I thought [__] it where is he where
is he and first thing I thought you know
he's dead you know and they they said no
he's gone in for emergency surgery
trying to save him do you ever miss the
military oh massively
massively without a doubt the resigning
nods then yeah oh I've got no purpose
the purpose I say it to my wife every
day I ring it every day I've got no I've
got no purpose
what's my purpose during the arm when I
was 16.
you know the 23 freaking years
and you introduced that's what happens
you become that person and then you
leave the Army you've lost civilians
don't understand the banter they don't
stand what you go through they don't
understand your PTSD they don't
understand war or anything and you just
feel you've got no purpose
you know you end up isolating yourself
I've got no uh I know Toby's in contact
with friends and family uh Marines and
all that me no one no one 23 years I
mean
I've got no comms with no one except my
number one and I saw my number two that
I used to sniper with
because we were close because you had to
be close as a sniper pair you know but
yeah that's really sad Craig yeah
and that's how I feel and I I it's
yeah I can understand that because in
Australia
showing the Afghan and
all right well
I think only 40 Australians were killed
but since the war 500 British Australian
soldiers have committed suicide
it's unbelievable isn't it
I do think having
a network of your friends that you did
serve with certainly it's got me through
my hard times in the last two years I'm
sure Toby will agree so you know maybe
time might change you might feel like
you want to connect with those but
equally see why people don't it's sort
of a way of just moving on to the next
chapter when I got diagnosed with cptsd
my regiment just disowned me
disown me what they put you in that
wounded soldier unit where you get an
officer attached to you I wasn't allowed
back in Camp or no one rang me from the
family's office ncos or nothing friends
that I thought were friends no one
around me [__] you I'm not waiting for
that I'd rather be on my own has a huge
feeling on Airport especially
considering when you've given to the
army of the year I think it's really a
huge feeling massive I think what I miss
as well is that you know we all wear a
rank in our name certainly on our flying
suit we have you know I was a flight
Sergeant McConaughey
and I wonder if that was so other people
knew who I was or if I so I knew who I
was because I could look at that every
day and go that's who I am it's a bit
like you could look at it and go
Sergeant Craig whatever and you you know
who you are by looking at that badge and
when you're stripped of that badge and
stripped of the uniform which
essentially becomes your identity you
know whenever I put my flying set on it
was like my Wonder Woman costume I was
that person and you it's not that you
felt you were Invincible but you felt
that you're a part of something you were
all there wearing the same uniform all
there as a big team and suddenly I was
just Liz from beers and Stoke walking
around Tesco's and I wasn't important to
anyone at all I get looked after from
my Squadron and my unit very well
and I feel terribly
upset Craig by what you've said that's
really like punched me right in the gut
um to the point where yeah I mean after
this I'm gonna go and yeah I have a word
with somebody because
that's yeah
um and I'll teach some more stuff off
camera as well it's disappointing me I
suspect you're not the only one though
that's what I think I'm sad is that this
is just your story and there's probably
about another you know 30 or 40 if not
hundreds of people like you and that's
quite the hydrating and some you know
they need to do something about that
especially considering what you give
if you if you could do it all over again
would you still join the military
oh yeah I'll join the Marines
that's what I would do hell yeah yeah
that's what I've done yeah even though
I'm in the situation now
um it was something I always wanted to
do and I'm proud of what I did
um yeah it was was the only damn thing I
was good at so yeah I wouldn't I
wouldn't change it for the world yeah
well I'll join if I thought it's worth
fighting for
it was defending my country
or my beliefs
that's my opinion anyway I think I would
anyway I don't know 100 years old I'm a
bit too old to join up again I think I
was you know absolutely supporter of the
queen loved the queen but I don't think
I ever you know went to Afghanistan to
serve Queen and Country I went because I
you know I wanted to go with my mates I
didn't want to not go through one of
them would go and catch up a bullet that
was meant for me and it's been part of
that team and
from a lot of the guys I've spoken to
you kind of want the guy left and right
of you to go with them you didn't
necessarily you know put on your uniform
and head off to foreign soils for
cleaning country it wasn't really about
that yes we all swore on Earth to the
queen but it was more about your mates
and your Band of Brothers that you went
to fight for I don't know if that means
that's right but
yeah certainly the vibe I got from most
people yeah yeah I I was shot
um and on a previous operation I was
shot in the arm
um through the shoulder and
after my time at um you know the
hospital at Bastion I was I was given
the opportunity to either go back home
for some r r and and so on and so forth
or I could stay out in the theater
because it wasn't that severe
[Music]
and I chose to stay out because of
exactly what you're talking about Liz I
didn't want some someone else coming out
and then thinking oh yeah I get to go
back and um
you know spend time in the UK and
someone else was out yeah who
potentially could catch it up
[Music]
so I was I was determined like
determined to start even though everyone
was telling me narutobes you know you
need to go back and get your head
straight and so on and so forth and sort
yourself out but um no I decided to stay
and um
yeah to no yeah a couple of weeks later
or whatever it was
um yeah I ended up getting shot in the
neck and paralyzed for life but
yeah I'd rather me than than somebody
else you know
or to live with that guilt that oh yeah
I went home and someone else came out
and is now in this position because I I
took the option or
for me the easy way out
um yeah
[Music]
the memory that stays with me of five
coffins with the Union flag over them
and the helicopter coming
and the dust and the sun setting
was that in Afghanistan that was in
Afghanistan
that was hard to deal with
because I've been there with them men
I was part of that explosion